>>> ONE YEAR AGO, MY DOCUMENTARY
ABOUT MICHAEL JORDAN'S FINAL
SEASON WITH THE BULLS, "THE LAST
DANCE," AIRED ON ESPN.
EVEN THOUGH IT WAS TEN HOURS
LONG, THERE WAS SO MUCH LEFT ON
THE CUTTING ROOM FLOOR.
SO TONIGHT, I'D LIKE TO SHARE AN
EXTENDED SCENE THAT I THINK
REALLY SPEAKS TO WHAT MADE
MICHAEL JORDAN SUCH A GREAT
COMPETITOR.
ENJOY.
>> GAME FIVE, BULLS/SUNS, TIPOFF
IS IN TWO HOURS, I AM PLAYING
QUARTERS ON THE WALL WITH MY
HEAD OF SECURITY, JOHN HERE,
JOHN, SAY HI.
LOOK OVER HERE.
SAY HI.
>> I'M READY FOR MY CLOSE UP.
>> SO, WHOEVER GETS A QUARTER
CLOSEST TO THE WALL WINS, I'M
ABOUT TO TAKE $5 OFF OF HIM.
NOW WATCH THIS.
>> WE'LL SEE.
OKAY.
>> OH!
HOW ABOUT I TAKE THAT FROM YOU?
OH.
I WIN!
>> HE WON.
I WAS HAPPY FOR HIM.
BUT HE DID THAT LITTLE SHRUG AND
I TOOK THAT PERSONALLY.
AGAIN.
>> OH, OKAY.
I THINK I GOT ANOTHER FIVE SIDE
ON ME.
>> $1,000 THIS TIME.
>> COME ON, MAN, I DON'T CARRY
THAT KIND OF -- WHAT DO THE KIDS
CALL IT, CHEESE?
>> I'LL SPOT YOU, I'LL SPOT YOU.
>> OH, NO.
>> OH, HO HO!
>> THAT IS FINANCIALLY ROUGH FOR
ME.
THE WIFE'S NOT GOING TO LIKE
THAT.
>> SEE, WITH MICHAEL, HE HAD TO
WIN.
THAT'S WHAT MADE HIM GREAT.
>> OH!
>> OH, [ BLEEP ]!
>> I MEAN, HE'S ABOUT TO PLAY
FOR AN NBA TITLE AND HERE HE IS
TAKING LITTLE LOCKER ROOM GAME
JUST AS SERIOUSLY, JUST AMAZING
COMPETITOR.
>> HOW MUCH MONEY YOU OWE ME
NOW?
>> 9,000.
>> AW, THAT'S NOTHING, MAN.
YOU CAN MAKE THAT IN A DAY.
>> I CAN'T.
>> YOU CAN.
UH-OH.
THERE HE IS.
THE AMAZING AND ALL RIGHT,
CHARLES BARKLEY.
>> WHAT'S UP, M.J.?
HOW YOU ALL DOING?
OH, WHAT YOU ALL PLAYING?
QUARTERS AGAINST THE WALL?
>> YEAH.
>> MAN, I LOVE THAT GAME!
LET ME PLAY.
WHAT YOU THINK, ABOUT 5,000 A
THROW?
>> OKAY, WELL, YOU TWO HAVE FUN.
>> NO, JOHN, STAY.
>> I DON'T MAKE THAT KIND OF
MONEY.
>> PUT YOUR PANTS IN.
>> NOT GOING TO LOOK GREAT IF I
LOSE MY PANTS, BUT --
WELL, IT IS THE DREAM TEAM.
>> THERE WE GO.
OH, LOOK AT THESE PLATES.
>> ALL RIGHT.
>> SHARP PLATES.
>> ALL RIGHT, COME ON, THEY
WOULDN'T EVEN FIT YOU, MAN.
LET ME WIN THEM BACK.
FOR THE PANTS.
>> OH, YOU TRIPPING, MAN.
>> THE THING ABOUT MIKE IS, HE
DIDN'T WANT TO JUST BEAT YOU.
HE WANTED TO DOMINATE YOU.
>> OH.
>> JOHN, I THINK YOU OWE ME A
GUN.
>> IT'S LOADED.
>> WHAT?
>> HE WANTED TO EMBARRASS YOU.
>> HE WAS THE BEST.
YOU SAID YOU'D SHOW IT.
>> OH!
>> OKAY, YOU KNOW WHAT, MAYBE IF
I WAS SEVEN FEET TALL, MINE
WOULD LOOK LIKE YOURS, ALL
RIGHT?
BUT YOU KNOW WHAT, HEY, IT'S A
STORY, I CAN TELL MY GRANDKIDS I
SHOWED MJ MY [ BLEEP ].
LET'S GO AGAIN.
>> IF YOU'RE NOT PLAYING TO WIN,
WHY PLAY?
>> YOU HUSSLING ME, M.J.
I'M GOING TO SETTLE THIS ON THE
COURT.
>> CHUCK, I'M GOING TO WHOOP
YOUR ASS, MAN.
HEY, JOHN, GIVE ME THOSE
GLASSES.
>> OH, I REALLY NEED THEM.
I'M SECURITY, I GOT TO BE ABLE
TO SEE.
>> A BET'S A BET.
A BET'S A BET.
>> YOU'RE RIGHT.
HE'S RIGHT.
>> ALL RIGHT.
>> I NEVER THROW QUARTERS AT THE
WALL WITH JORDAN.
I WOULDN'T DO IT.
>> JOHN.
>> WAIT, WHERE'D HE GO?
>> I LOST EVERYTHING ONCE.
>> OKAY, ONE MORE TIME.
LET'S GO, COME ON.
>> I AIN'T GOT NOTHING LEFT.
>> ONE NIGHT WITH YOUR WIFE.
>> NO, MAN, THAT'S TOO FAR.
ALL RIGHT, LET'S GO.
COME ON, COME ON.
DON'T BE LIKE THAT, BECAUSE IT'S
JUST ONE NIGHT AND -- HELLO?
OKAY, WELL, SHE HUNG UP, SO.
IT'S OFFICIAL, I'M IN THE DOG
HOUSE.
>> JOHN, LET'S GO.
COME ON, COME ON.
ONE MORE, LET'S GO.
>> I GOT TO SAY NO.
>> IF YOU WIN, I'M GOING TO GIVE
YOU EVERYTHING BACK.
YOU'RE GOING TO GET YOUR RING,
YOU'RE GOING TO GET YOUR GUN.
YOU GOING TO GET YOUR PANTS.
EVERYTHING.
COME ON.
>> WHAT DO YOU GET?
>> WHAT DO I GET?
YOUR HAIR.
>> YOU HAVE A PROBLEM.
>> WHAT CAN I SAY?
I LIKE TO WIN.